[موسيقى]
لا تلعبوا بالنار فنحن لم ندخل مرحله الجد
بعد وما هذه الا البدايه واسراب الموت
الروسيه تغزو والنتيجه كارثيه بينما اكثر
من 500 واربعين جنديا اوكرانيا تم تحييدهم
خلال ليله واحده والسعوديه تستعد لتعوض
مجموعه بريكس عن الدول الغربيه وامريكا
تلطم على خديها وروسيا تقف مع حليفتها
صربيا وكوسوفو هي الهدف القادم دول
اوروبيه تنشق عن الصف الغربي وزيرنسكي
يرفع ورقه الحرب ضد ايران واردوغان يلقي
خطاب النصر متواعدا امريكا واوروبا وكارثه
غير مالوفه تحل في الجزائر والاداره
الامريكيه تستبق الموعد المحدد وتعلن عن
حل لسقف الدين
عمليه الاحماء الروسيه الحرب احالت كل شيء
في اوكرانيا الى الخراب الدمار جاب البلاد
من ادناها الى اقصاها وبعد كل ذلك روسيا
تعلنها نحن لا زلنا في مرحله الاحماء فقط
ولم ندخل الجد بعد وها هو وزير الخارجيه
الروسي
يلعب بالنار باستعداده للسماح من دول اخرى
بتزويد بمقاتلات اف 16 هناك حضرت موسكو من
انها لم تتصرف بجديه كبيره بعد في هذه
المواجهه اي ان الرؤوس لم يبدا الحرب بجد
وما هذه الا البدايه اذا فكيف ستكون
النهايه يا ساده لكن الغرب هنا يعترفون
بان مقاتلات اف 16 التي يجري الاستعداد
لامداد اوكرانيا بها ستكون ضعيفه ولن تصمد
امام الدفاعات الجويه الروسيه وذلك بحسب
صحيفه بلومبر حيث رجحت الصحيفه ان
اوكرانيا هذه المقاتلات لتعزيز دفاعاتها
الجويه فقط او في العمليات الخاصه وهنا
الرئيس البيلاروسيا الكسندر لوكيشنكو يعزز
موسكو سياسيا قائلا ان العمليه الروسيه
العسكريه الخاصه كانت حتميه ولو لم تبدا
في فبراير 2022 لانطلقت بجميع الاحوال في
وقت لاحق لكن بالظروف اسوا لياتي هنا
التاكيد الروسي على ان الحرب الحقيقيه لم
تبدا بعد حيث زادت القوات الروسيه من شده
ضرباتها قليلا وفي ذكرى تاسيسها تعرضت
العاصمه الاوكرانيه كييف لاعنف هجوم
بالمسيرات المتفجره منذ اندلاع الصراع
ليعيش سكان العاصمه ليله مرعبه لم يعيشوها
من قبل لوكد الجيش الاوكراني تدمر اثنتين
وخمسين مسيره من اصل 54 مسيره متفجره
ارسلت خلال الليل اسراب المسيرات الروسيه
تغزو اجواء كييف في هجوم ليلي يعد الاكبر
منذ بدء الحرب فماذا بعد المسيرات ايها
الدب الروسي ليس ذلك فحسب بل ان الجيش
الروسي اعلن تحيده نحو
545 عسكريا اوكرانيا واسقاط ثلاثه صواريخ
كروز من طراز ستورم شادو البريطانيه لياتي
الرد الاوكراني على لسان الامين العام
لمجلس الامن القومي اوكسي لقوله ان
اوكرانيا مستعده لاطلاق هجومها المضاد
ليونيل نحو 400 جندي اوكراني في المانيا
بداوا تدريبات على تشغيل وصيانات الدبابات
الامريكيه بينما قال هيئه الاركان انها
سجلت 25 اشتباكا مع القوات الروسيه خلال
الساعات الاخيره وصفه الهجمات الروسيه على
بالفاشله ومعلنه صدها هجمات على مدينه
الاوكراني يواصلون ردهم وهذه المره كشف
مقر العمليات في اقليم كرسنال الروسي عن
محاوله عده مسيرات الاقتراب
الاقليم مضيفا انه تم القضاء عليها دون
الحاق اي ضرر بالمصنع لننتقل الى اوروبا
حيث بدا الصف الغربي بالانقسام وهنا انضمت
اليونان الى هنغاريا في الامتناع عن تطبيق
حزمه العقوبات الاوروبيه المرتقبه ضد
روسيا فهل تلحق اليونان بذلك بمركب بوتين
كما فعلت هنغاريا من قبلها ومن حرب
العقوبات ننتقل الى معارك الحلفاء حيث
قالت الخارجيه الروسيه ان موسكو ستواصل
دعم صربيا في حمايه حقوقها وسيادتها
وسلامه اراضيها مشدده على ان اي قرار
يجب ان يكون مقبولا بالنسبه للصرب ويوافق
عليه مجلس الامن الدولي لتضيف موسكو انها
تراقب بقلق تدهور الاوضاع في اقليم كوسوفو
فهذا التدور يهدد بشكل مباشر امن منطقه
البلقان باكملها وذلك بحسب وكاله اما
الرئيس الاوكراني
من جانبه فقد طرح على البرلمان الاوكراني
مشروع قرار بشان فرض عقوبات على جمهوريه
ايران لمده 50 عاما بذريعه امداد ايران
لروسيا بالاسلحه وكان قد دعى في وقت سابق
السلطات الايرانيه الى وقف دعمها لروسيا
وقال رئيس المخابرات الاوكرانيه
يمكنها نظريا شنو ضربه لتدمير الشركات
التي تنتج طائرات مسيره في ايران لكن مهلا
مهلا هل استطاعت اوكرانيا ان تصد الهجمات
الروسيه حتى تمتلك القدره على حرب ايران
يا له من تهديد اوكراني غريب وعجيب وبعيدا
عن اوكرانيا وحربها افادت صحيفه بان
السعوديه تجري محادثات للانضمام الى مصرف
التنميه الجديده التابعي لمجموعه
العربيه السعوديه لهذه المنظمه سيعزز
العلاقات بين اعضاء المصرف الذي انشاته
اكبر الاقتصادات الناشئه في العالم كبديل
بمؤسسات بريتموود بقياده الغرب
تركيا تزف عريسها الجديد
اقتراح تركي يبوح بكل اسراره لتدخل
الانتخابات الرئاسيه التركيه التاريخ من
اوسع ابوابه فهي الاولى من نوعها التي جرت
فيها جوله اعاده ثانيه لكن الجوله الثانيه
لم تاتي بجديد حيث حقق المرشح الرئاسي
للتحالف الجمهور رجب طيب اردوغان فوزا
صعبا على منافسه مرشح تحالف الشعب كمال
جلج دار اوغلو لتعلن تركيا اردوغان رئيسا
لها حتى عام 2022 اما في الجانب الاخر
للانتخابات فظهرت مشاهد غير مالوفه حيث
وثقت مقاطع فيديو وصول المنتخبين الاتراك
الى مراكز الاقتراع في مدن متفرقه في
تركيا فبعضهم وصل رفقه عنزه واخر مع ببغاء
للتصويت شارك عروسان لحظات من يوم عرسهما
لاختيار الرئيس
الاحداث والتطورات
اعلن الرئيس صربي الكسندر بوتشيتش تنحيه
عن رئاسه الحزب التقدمي الصربي الحاكم
واقترح ان يحل وزير الدفاع ميلوسبوزيتش
محله في رئاسه الحزب اثرت السيول
والفيضانات التي شهدتها ولايات عده شماليه
الجزائر نهايه الاسبوع الماضي عن مقتل
طفلين اضافه الى خسائر ماديه كبيره بسبب
تضرر ابنيه ومساحات زراعيه وعدد من موانئ
الصيد الصغيره وتعرضت مدينه فوكا بولايه
تيبازه غرب العاصمه لخسائر ماديه كبيره
كارثه جعلت الجزائر يعيش في حاله صعبه فهل
تكون هذه الكارثه اخر الاحزان للجزائريين
نتمنى ذلك اعلن رئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي
كابل عن توصله لاتفاق مبدئي مع البيت
الابيض بشان سقف الدين قبل الموعد النهائي
المحدد من قبل وزاره الخ في الخامس من
يونيو حزيران ما الذي يتعلق بعدم قدره
الحكومه على سداد التزامات الفيدراليه
وقال مقارتي ان الاتفاق يشمل تخفيضات
تاريخيه في الانفاق مؤكدا انه لا يتضمن اي
زياده في الضرائب او برامج جديده عاشت
العاصمه الاوكرانيه ليله لن يسبق لها مثيل
بعد تحليق اسراب المسيرات الروسيه فوقها
فهل تكون هذه الليله بدايه لعهد جديد من
تصعيد الحرب بين موسكو
[موسيقى]